but meanwhile miguel cabrera has been
waiting over a week for home run number
500 and he is giving it to his back
right now
make his 24th start of the season just
his third career start against the
tigers and he hasn't faced them since
2017 so it's an entirely different
roster he's looking at it change up but
he'll get a lot of swings and misses on
that pitch
and he got one right there to ring him
up one down
all right when ryu's changeup is
down and he's throwing it over the plate
he's going to have a good outing and
this is a perfect pitch he got scoped to
chase all those pitches off the plate
outside and with two strikes this is one
of the best two strike hitters in the
game and he had no chance there now
reece has finally gotten to that pitch
short hop by buchet flipped to simeon
onto first for two
a rocket off the bat of grossman but the
blue jays turn the double play to retire
the side for your tigers today it's
willie peralta hitters in the batters
box have no way of eliminating pitches
because of the usage of his pitches he
uses he utilizes all of his pitches
and he's really really good ship when he
keeps those pitches down and out of the
middle of the plate
sharply the third
cleanly played the turn in time
we saw time and time again last night
the tigers do it again already here in
the first and it helps willie peralta to
a seven pitch inning here comes miguel
cabrera making a bid for 500.
2-0 and an off-speed pitch grounded to
third espinal's got it and with cabrera
running he knows he's got time one down
left-hand hitting harold castro bounces
one down to vladimir guerrero and it's a
three-up three-down inning on groundouts
for hyunjin ryu looking sharp in the
early going
and santiago espinal with a base hit
through the right side in his first
at-bat of the ball game so espinal
hitting seventh randall grichik hitting
eighth again which he has done on
occasion recently as he lifts a fly ball
to left field
and it is gone
into the blue jay bullpen for a two-run
home run and a second inning lead
boy rando has been a little bit of a
funk laidly and that's the reason he's
dropped down to a spot but he comes up
big time how about a two out single by
aspen allman glitching with a two-run
home run here in the second
so randall connects for his 21st home
run two more rbis he's got 74.
and that's what the blue jays needed to
stake their pitcher to an early lead
give him a little breath
and ryu gets a fastball by him at 92 to
strike him out on three pitches
brielle
has all of his pitches early in this
game and now i just got to make sure he
continues to throw quality pitches it's
just a fastball upstairs as ryu took a
page out of richard's book and strikes
out short once again
3-2 on the way and it's popped up
ladies got a play in foul territory and
the side is retired
one two to beau bechet swung on and
missed
and already
willie peralta has taken care of beau
bechet twice one of the more dangerous
hitters in the blue jays lineup in the
american league well this is just filled
here guys that ball look where it is
this starts at the top of the strike
zone there so you see it there as a
hitter and then when it gets in the
hitting zone the bottom falls out
3-0
he's turning on it
this could be two the relay in time how
about that they gave him the green light
on 3-0 he swung
and he paid for it second double play
for the tigers in the ball game miguel
cabrera bats third in the fourth now the
tigers big dog grounded to third his
first time up
ground ball to short beshette to second
simeon taking his time and there's the
double play
to retire the side to the bottom of the
fourth blue jays coming out leading two
to nothing
dickerson strikes out swinging there's
two away there's that split finger
fastball changing the eye level of corey
dickerson
a chop ball off the plate weekly hit
towards third charging in candelario's
got it he'll throw to first in time
guriel is retiring the blue jays return
to side
got him to chase a change up swung so
hard his helmet came off candelario down
on strikes for out number one well that
changeup has been good from the first
pitch of this ball game he struck out
jonathan's scope in the first inning
with a similar pitch in the same
location down and away and candelario a
switch hitter look how far out in front
of that pitch he was
and he got it great job by ryu to get
out of it after the one out double
still two-nothing blue jays
swing and a miss were you using the
change up again strikeout number five
guerrero's got it puts the tag on
grossman and the side is retired it
doesn't matter if you're a tigers fan or
a blue jays fan in toronto today you
know when miguel cabrera steps to the
plate his third at bat coming here to
lead off the seventh
the payoff to
cabrera and he walked him
right now it's up to tim mays making his
46th appearance he last pitched against
washington
2-2
got him
maguire down to first
to retire the side what a good inning by
tim masons onto the bottom of the gate
blue jays up two to nothing two down for
marcus simeon as the tigers put the
shift on again
and this one is crushed to left field
into the second deck
number 30 for marcus simeon and it is
three to nothing aaron hill is the only
other blue jay middle infielder hit 30
or more home runs in a season and now
marcus simeon has that distinction as
well
blue jays need to be winners here this
afternoon and they've got a three-run
lead going to the ninth inning and now
the guy they won on the mound in this
spot jordan romano out to face the top
of the tiger lineup derek hill jonathan
scope and robbie grossman
swing and a miss one down
scope strikes out for a second time he's
over four
but not here
swinging a miss two down and miguel
cabrera is coming up he's hit seven home
runs at rogers center
slider to get him and that's the ball
game
romano strikes out cabrera for the
second time in as many days
and the blue jays pick up a much-needed
victory this afternoon
you